das hat gesessen beyonces performance
beim super bowl finale weltweit flimmert
ihre kampfansage über die bildschirme
der auftritt provokativ und hoch
symbolisch vor einem millionen-publikum
eine hommage an merke max und die black
panthers jene bürgerrechtsbewegung die
zum bewaffneten widerstand gegen die
unterdrückung der schwarzen aufrief
schwarze protest musik ist wieder zurück
und sie ist populärer als je zuvor denn
die hoffnung auf barack obama war riesig
luksic sieht dem früheren blues sekunden
musik von flyniki vor kampf um
gleichberechtigung und nachhaltiger
übernachtung von obama ist ein großes
ihrer achtlose geplatzt die lizenzen
oder was saison geht verloren und jetzt
erweist sich amerika aus was ich noch
nicht rassistische denn je aber es ist
gut sichtbar denn je wie rassistisch
gespalten protest kommt von patric
lemmer in einer der ärmsten gegenden von
los angeles aufgewachsen ist er die
stimme junge afroamerikaner sind von
seinen und ihren erfahrungen mit
alltäglichen rassismus und
diskriminierung
es klingt tragisch aber so spannend war
schwarze musik schon lange nicht mehr
froh dass sie jedes auto grundprinzip
wieder zurück es geht und das ist
gemeine daran es verleiht der black
music wieder die dringlichkeit und also
der band hat sich auch beim hafer wurde
zweimal von der polizei irrtümlich
festgenommen
in seiner aktuellen single zählt er die
jüngst ermordeten auf
während harper anklagt feiert pop queen
beyoncé trotzig den american dream
und der vermarktungs profi promotet sich
gleich noch als schwarze jeanne d'arc
vielleicht auch weil revolution sich gut
verkauft politik oder kalkül von
möglichst vielen amerikanerinnen damen i
pod pleite der gauchos vom größten
fehler ereignis und das ist das super
bowl und ich finde das großartig gemacht
klar kann man sage ja jetzt nur
mainstream und du bist sowieso
millionärin aber das sind sie ja sagen
diese richtung ist die beste rache die
besten acht ist dass die millionärin
worden
doch was kann musik bewirken kann
beyoncé polizeigewalt verhindern kann ja
mal etwas daran ändern dass die
gefängnisse voll mit schwarzem sind aber
das muss mehr denn je
sie liefert den wissen für den kampf
gegen unterdrückung
mit